Speaker 1: Last week, we reported to you that
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi would be
stepping down from leadership of the Democratic
Party. Democrats, of course, poised to become
the minority party in the House of Representatives
based on the November 8th election results in the
2022 midterms. Nancy Pelosi stepping down but will
stay in Congress. And Democrats have now decided
that it is. Hakeem Jeffries, a former guest of
this program, who will become minority leader
for Democrats in the House of Representatives.
The New York Times reporting in a show of unity,
House Democrats select Hakeem Jeffries,
Minority Leader, a new trio, including
Representatives Katherine Clarke of Massachusetts
as number two, and Pete Aguilar of California as
number three will take the reins in January,
replacing Speaker Nancy Pelosi and her team.
Jeffries is 52 years old. Clarke is 59
and Aguilar is 43. Certainly moving in
the direction of Younger, which is something
that many Democrats have been calling for. Now,
it shouldn't surprise anyone. If you've been
following American politics for any period of time
to know that the right is immediately framing and
attacking Hakeem Jeffries as some kind of extreme
radical. Of course, the reality is that he is
nothing of the sort. And I would encourage you,
if you really just want to see the way that he
presents himself and talks about issues and thinks
through issues. Check out my interview with Hakeem
Jeffries from some years ago. The topics will be
less relevant to 2022, but it is of course still
the same. Hakeem Jeffries here is Newsmax with
a commentary on Hakeem Jeffries. They are saying
much of the decision was motivated simply by race
and the fact that Hakeem Jeffries is not white.
And they say a lot of the exact things that we
would expect. But it's important to remember they
would be saying this no matter who was chosen.
Speaker 2: All right. Other news tonight,
Democrats picked to replace Nancy Pelosi
indicates that their party has no intention of
veering away from the squad's favorite brand
of politics. Hakeem Jeffries is an anti US oil
rabid defender of the pro-abortion death cult.
He's an election denier. He's a pretty radical
New York congressman. He tweeted numerous times
following the 2016 election, at one point
writing, The more we learn about the 2016
election, the more illegitimate it becomes.
Speaker 1: Now you need to understand they
love to play this game. So, first of all, some
of the things that that this Newsmax host says,
well, he's part of the pro-abortion, pro,
pro-death machine, abortion, whatever
he, like most Americans, supports abortion rights.
That's not super controversial, but everything has
to be framed as completely outrageous. On Newsmax,
when you are perpetuating this brand of fear and
outrage, politics that has completely supplanted
policy for the American right wing. This issue of
election denier, you know, when people on the left
questioned the legitimacy of Trump's presidency,
they were not literally saying it was stolen in
the way that Trump has said about 2020. There
were sort of two meanings to Trump as illegitimate
as president. One meaning was that Trump rose to
the presidency on the shoulders of foreign
support from Russia. And of course, that's
been demonstrated now. Of course, it has not been
demonstrated that Trump and Putin got together in
eight frog's legs while plotting exactly how Putin
would do it. But we know Russia had a preference
for Trump over Hillary and used social media and
other influence avenues to try to make it so that
Trump would win and not Hillary Clinton. It's not
do the election over. It's people were swayed by
propaganda that came from a foreign adversary.
Okay. Very, very different. And the number two,
Trump was illegitimate in the colloquial sense
in that he had no business being president of
the United States, had no idea what was going on,
didn't know up from down, was completely clueless.
It is not fair to say that those are election
deniers in the way that people are going around,
like Marjorie Taylor GREENE literally saying,
oh, more people actually tried to vote for Trump,
but Joe Biden manipulated the machines or
whatever the case may be not even remotely
comparable. And it's important to understand
that when they pull that line out. Let's
listen to a little bit more of this.
Speaker 2: And now this man leads with
House Democrats. So you see the road that that
party is going down. Republican strategist Erin
Perrine joins me now to talk more about this.
Good to see you, Aaron. It's a pretty radical
choice. I'm not surprised because you knew
it wasn't going to be a white guy. I think
we all knew that. But it's a very extreme choice.
Speaker 3: It is an extreme choice. And Democrats
like to use this adage, right, show me your
budget and I'll show you your values. Well,
show me your leader and I'll show you your
party. They have picked an election denier,
you know. A Green New Deal loving champion of
Russian disinformation, Hakeem Jeffries, to lead.
Speaker 1: And of course, that's completely
inaccurate. And there is really nothing at
all radical about Hakeem Jeffries. I think
that Jeffries does have a very difficult
position and timing. He is entering leadership
of the Democratic Party as Democrats have lost
control of the House, number one. And number two,
as Republicans are particularly incentivized to
make the next two years about, you know, Hunter
Biden and maybe even Hillary Clinton's emails,
if you could imagine. So a difficult time
to become part of Democratic leadership,
but an interesting choice. Brilliant guy.
Check out his interview with me some years ago